but first after several feeble
painstaking steps
up the stairs once again to air force
one
in the wind and the rain the very frail
the very weak the
cognitively struggling joe biden made
his way to pittsburgh pennsylvania where
he unveiled
what is a massive multi-trillion dollar
tax hike
the largest in history and green new
energy program disguised as an
infrastructure bill which it is not
sort of like the emergency covett bill
was not about emergency covert relief
in fact out of the roughly 2.3 trillion
dollars in new spending
yeah only 650 billion is allocated for
roads
and bridges and general infrastructure
eighty billion that's marked as a
handout to amtrak
the rest of the two point three trillion
dollars
that is dedicated to retrofitting
millions of homes and hospitals and
other buildings
in an environmentally conscious way and
other funds would go towards building
new green schools
400 billion of your hard-earned tax
dollars
of this so-called infrastructure bill
that'll be used to expand medicaid
and of course billions more would be
used to permanently cap
permanently cap oil and gas wells
bet vladimir putin i bet the malls in
iran i bet all these countries that hate
us in the middle east
they're doing backflips and celebrating
tonight
and of course in order to pay for all of
this joe biden is proposing
the most expansive tax increase in the
history of the country
but according to joe he's telling you no
one under 400 000
a year will be affected watch this
so here's what i do i start with one
rule
no one we said again no one making under
four
hundred thousand dollars will see
their federal taxes go up period
this is not about penalizing anyone
i have nothing against millionaires and
billionaires i believe
american american capitalism ah
joe looks so tired but let's cut through
all the clutter joe biden
right there is lying and he's been lying
a lot lately
you know like his staff saying oh the
wind blew him
to the ground three times while boarding
air force one
oh and most people on the border know
we're sending most of them back
and that his border problem was caused
by donald trump
make no mistake if you have a pulse
whether you make a million dollars a
year or
a hundred dollars a year i'm telling you
tonight your bank account will
suffer under joe's proposals and all of
biden's radical environmental policies
you will be helping to pay for if in all
even
possible let's break it down now if
passed high income earners
well they're going to have 40 percent of
their income wiped out by the federal
government immediately
if they invest that money get a capital
gains they'll take another bite at the
apple
that's not all when you die they get 50
more
the corporate tax rate we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna go after those greedy
corporations
yeah that tax goes up significantly but
let's be clear
what joe's not telling you large
corporations
they're not going to eat joe's tax
increase and take the loss
not even a little bit corporations will
do what they always do
they will pass those costs on to you and
the consumer
the american people meaning almost
anything and everything you buy
any service you use will be more
expensive they'll be charging more
and then you couple that with the biden
administration's war on oil and gas and
energy
well that's causing energy prices to
shoot through the roof as you already
know
and you'll be looking at steep price
increases going
further higher on pretty much everything
in other words
if what you're buying is transported on
a truck
or a ship then they're paying more money
for gas and fuel
guess what you'll take the burden of
paying higher prices for everything you
purchase
and by the way when you go to fill up
your gas tank heat and cool your homes
you're already paying more and remember
this war on oil and gas
it has already destroyed thousands and
thousands of high-paying career jobs
in the energy sector and the biden
administration
well they just told these americans they
fired through the stroke of a pen
i'll go find another good union job in
the middle of a pandemic
while we're legalizing 15 million
illegal immigrants
that are also going to be competing for
jobs where are the jobs joe
because we've looked we've not located a
single new clean energy job
that your administration has created not
one
now if we learned anything from the
biden and obama and solyndra
shovel ready jobs error the so-called
infrastructure bill
is doomed to fail those jobs weren't
shovel ready they were non-existent
they were literally shuffling nothing
but schiff
and that was all that was shoveled they
were shoveling shift
and tonight the cherry on the top is the
legislation's commitment to ending the
right to work
let me explain what this means every
state now will be just like new york
just like illinois and california where
the all
powerful public sector unions in their
unholy alliance with the democratic
party
they will run the show by the way all
you union leaders
great the job they did ending those
union jobs in in the energy sector
so make no mistake just like new york
california illinois
corruption inefficiency insanely high
state and local taxes will become your
new normal
no matter where you live